good morning john a few weeks after my
second book came out i started working
on a new thing and then i stopped
working on it i thought to myself
you know i don't think i can really
write this until after the election
because
the world is just gonna be so different
depending on how that goes so here's the
thing as of the recording of this video
we don't even know
who was elected but regardless i have
realized that it is not going to be
different in the way that i imagined
i thought we were going to have one of
two things happen either we were gonna
like
roundly denounce this thing that is
trumpism or
we as a country would decide that we
accept that this is the right way to be
doing things and those two worlds were
very different from the world i was
living in
and very different from each other and
so i felt like i couldn't write anything
without knowing which of those worlds it
was going to take place in but
i always tell myself i say this all the
time all dichotomies are false
dichotomies
even that one because there are some
true dichotomies and it turns out that
uh we may have found a middle path now
i'm not saying that this election
doesn't matter it matters tremendously
and a lot of ways
for a lot of people this goes the way i
think it will it's a bit of a lifeboat
we can't collectively
agree that that was the right thing to
do if biden is ultimately elected i
think that will be seen by a lot of
people
as a failure of trumpism but it's close
enough that donald trump can
of course falsely claim that the
election was stolen from him and a lot
of his followers his supporters will
completely lose faith in the american
system this rift has been crafted for
decades and i think a lot of people who
crafted it didn't think
or hope that it would get this deep but
it has and it was not going to get
filled in in one election i had that
hope and that was a faulty hope the
evening of november 3rd 2020
as florida began to turn red was the
first time
in my life that it has made sense that
donald trump is the president of the
united states i spent four years
just thinking it was surreal like that
guy the reality tv guy with the hair
that guy is the president and the way
that he talked the way that he behaved
it didn't make it any less bizarre
because of course it didn't tightly
align with how i imagined a president
should behave but as the lord it turned
red
it began to make sense to me that we
have a right-wing populist president
right now
because there are a lot of people in
this country who believe
that there are people who are not real
americans
who are making their lives worse what
makes them not real americans might be a
cultural thing that they're like a
coastal elite they're a fancy journalist
they're not a real
man whatever that is it might be a
racial thing
that you're not a real american if
you're not white or if you weren't born
here or if your parents weren't born
here it's almost always a politicized
oversimplified thing like you're not a
real american if you don't support the
police
and sometimes it's just an authoritarian
thing you're not a real american if you
don't support donald trump which is a
thing
that i think some people really do
believe we
are as individuals and as a nation
constantly
creating and expressing our values
elections highlight that in ways that
are
sometimes hopeful sometimes really
distressing i've been finding it
impossible to have any take about this
election that i believe for more than 30
minutes before changing my mind
except this one it was never going away
if texas had flipped it would not have
gone away but at least i am glad to have
the mirror held up
so that we can understand a little bit
better what things look like and the
work
of course goes on regardless john i'll
see you on tuesday
seriously thanks so much to everybody
who was a part of the political process
this time it doesn't always feel great
but it is vital